[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be counting down the top ten
biggest mysteries in Dragon Ball super I
am talking about all of those major
unanswered questions that we are hoping
will be answered at some point during
the series but with the announcement
that Dragon Ball super will stop airing
weekly on Japanese TV at the end of
March 2018 these unsolved mysteries are
now more important than ever because
many of us are afraid that the series
will end before we get a proper answer
to these questions
now of course I'm hoping that Dragon
Ball super will continue at some point
and that the upcoming break is just a
short hiatus before the series picks up
again I know that my Saturday nights
will not be the same without a weekly
dose of Dragon Ball super and whether
the series continues as Dragon Ball
super or under some other name
Dragon Ball ultra Dragon Ball Odyssey
whatever I will definitely be watching
it when it comes out but for now let's
take a look at those ten big mysteries
that we desperately want to see solved
before the end of the series some of
these mysteries i've already discussed
in other videos and every video that i
mentioned here will be linked down in
the description although I always
encourage feedback in the comments for
this video especially I want to hear
your thoughts about the biggest
mysteries that you want to see solved in
Dragon Ball super if you enjoy the
Dragon Ball super content on this
channel and want to see more be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and we are now posting daily anime
content on Twitter and Instagram you can
follow us there at anime uproar starting
things off with mystery number 10 where
is the Dragon gods allama Dragon Ball
super gets its name from the super
Dragon Balls and in the series we
learned that the creator of super
Shenron and the super Dragon Balls was
the Dragon
gods a llama Salameh created the super
Dragon Balls in year 41 of the divine
calendar and Salama must have had
unbelievable power because he created
super Shenron and super shen runs power
to grant a wish is limitless super
Shenron is able to kill gods of
destruction grant immortality and even
destroy entire universes Vegeta and
others are assuming that he can also
bring back entire universes after they
have been erased and of course Vegeta
wants to use the super Dragon Balls to
bring back universe 6 but the question
is where is this incredibly powerful
Dragon God that created the super Dragon
Balls in the first place we've met the
Omni King the grand priests the angels
the gods of destruction and other
deities but we still don't know what
happened to Salama after he created the
super Dragon Balls is Salama out there
somewhere in the multiverse but even
though he is a divine being he simply
doesn't care about the tournament of
powers so that's why we've never met him
did he somehow die and is no longer
among the living
even though it is hard to imagine that a
being with the ability to grant
immortality to others could die there
are some interesting theories about
Salama out there and in my video called
the Omni King has a secret I proposed a
theory that the Dragon gods allama might
actually be xennos true form I argued
that due to the fact that super Shenron
has limitless power the only creature in
the universe that could have had the
power to create him is Zeno Zeno is also
the only one who was able to destroy
sama soo despite the fact that the masu
was granted immortality by the super
Dragon Balls and who could undo the
power of the super Dragon Balls if not
their creator I speculated that perhaps
the Lamas power was too great for him to
maintain so like Frieza he created a
less imposing form in order to keep his
power in check with the drawback being
that in his smaller form he becomes
childish and innocent like Zeno seems to
be but this is just a theory since we
have no way of knowing for sure who or
what the dragon gods a Lama truly is
but that is exactly why I am hoping that
we will learn more about Salama before
Dragon Ball super ends since the Dragon
Ball franchise is based around the idea
of dragons and Dragon Balls it would be
disappointing for me not to find out
more about such a being as an
all-powerful dragon God be sure to give
me your thoughts and theories about
Salama down in the comments I bet we can
get some interesting conversations going
at number 9 what really happened to the
other six universes the universes that
were erased by Zeno before the universe
survival saga before the tournament of
power even begins we learn from we's
that there were once 18 universes rather
than twelve but the other six universes
were erased because Zeno was in a
spoiled mood or bad mood
but why was Zeno in a bad mood and why
did he decide to erase these six
universes in particular but not the
other twelve
I've always wondered whether something
happened inside of these six universes
to make Zeno angry perhaps a villain
like samus who emerged inside one of
these universes and managed to corrupt
those six before Zeno put a stop to it
by simply erasing them all and even if
Zeno decided to erase these six
universes completely at random I am
still wondering what was inside of these
universes what happened to the Angels
who were assigned to these universes we
haven't seen them in Dragon Ball super
so far so were they erased or are they
simply taking it easy somewhere since
they are currently unemployed some have
suggested in the comments on previous
videos that the reasons that all got mad
and erased the six universes was because
of what happened at the all universe
hide-and-seek tournament in the manga
but as far as we know this event took
place with only 12 universes
participating so it must have taken
place after the other six universes were
already erased the truth about these six
universes is one of the biggest
mysteries for me personally one that I
really want answered sometime in the
future my hope has always been that all
eighteen universes would be revived
after
the tournament of power either by using
the super Dragon Balls or by xeno
himself because I really want to see
what the other six universes look like
and I think that exploring them could be
a really cool plot point later on in the
series if Dragon Ball super does
continue after March and I really hope
that it does I am looking forward to
finding out more about these six
universes at number eight is future Z no
going to disrupt the present timeline
one of the most frequent comments that
I've gotten on previous Theory videos
are comments about future Zeno and how
his existence in the present timeline
effects the multiverse some have
suggested that future Zeno might become
a villain and I've even seen comments
that argue that future Zanna was somehow
corrupted or possessed by infinite imasu
meaning that the masu from the future
timeline might use future Zeno and his
power to get revenge and take over the
present timeline I don't know about that
but I do agree that having two supreme
beings with virtually unlimited powers
including the power to erase all of
existence can become problematic
what happens if Zeno and future zento
ever have a disagreement about something
what if they get into a fight their
incredible powers clashing or coming
into conflict in any way could spell
disaster for the multiverse so future
xenos presence in the current timeline
could definitely have a disruptive
effect at some point the fact is that
future zento does not belong in the
present timeline and since he lived
through things that present Zeno did not
and has different experiences the two
xenos are not necessarily the same
person some sort of war between the
xenos would definitely be a crazy twist
and it would create a lot of drama but I
don't think that a direct conflict
between them is even possible because
their powers combined would simply
destroy all of existence at number 7
what is the true nature of Goku's ultra
instinct omen transformation earlier on
in the series we stels us that ultra
instinct is a technique that allows the
body to move in battle without thinking
and we know that others have been seen
using it in the anime and manga so we
that ultra instinct is not unique to
Saiyans but there is something different
about Goku's ultra instinct
transformation yes Goku uses a technique
known as ultra instinct but he also
transforms in order to use it
Goku actually attains a new form which
allows him to use ultra instinct a form
which changes his appearance his eyes
change color and become silver his aura
becomes drastically different and the
first time he transforms his voice seems
to echo just like it did when he first
attained the Super Saiyan form in the
original Japanese dub when we see and be
ruse for beerus however you want to
pronounce it use the ultra and stick
technique themselves their appearance
does not change but Goku actually
transforms in order to use it so he does
obtain a new form this new form is most
commonly referred to as ultra instinct
omen which is how it was named in the
dragon ball z dokkan battle game we have
to remember them when goku first
achieves this new form both the grand
priest and wheeze are not sure what
exactly is happening they are both
obviously very familiar with ultra
instinct and they realize that Goku is
now able to use this technique but there
is also something unique about Goku's
transformation for example wheeze is
genuinely surprised by the massive
amount of heat that Goku is generating
in this state and then in episode 115 as
Goku is about to transform during his
battle with kefla we see him using the
ultra instinct technique to dodge kepis
attacks before he fully transforms into
this new form this to me confirms that
ultra instinct is a technique that Goku
is learning to master with the help of
this new form but the new form itself is
more than just the ultra instinct
technique for more details on this you
can check out my video called Goku's
ultra instinct is not what we thought
link in the description and if we accept
that Goku's ultra instinct omen goes
beyond just the ultra instinct technique
then the question is what is the true
nature of
this new form is this transformation the
first in a brand new family of
transformation a form which will have
its own Super Saiyan version like the
Super Saiyan God form has the Super
Saiyan blue after all the word omen
means a sign of things to come and if
this is the case what will this new
transformation look like and will it be
enough to finally defeat genin feel free
to let me know what you think down below
but personally I can't wait to find out
at number 6 what is the true purpose of
the Angels officially we have been told
that the Angels act as assistants or
attendants to the gods of destruction
and of course they also serve as the
teachers and guide when we learned that
the Angels are the only beings who will
not be erased along with their universes
during the tournament of power we six
planes this by saying that his position
as an angel is different than the
position of the other deities and all of
the other beings in the universe we know
that angels have destructive power like
the gods of destruction and the powers
of creation we scan even turn back time
for 3 minutes which is an incredibly
powerful and useful ability so knowing
all of this is it really possible that
the angels are just attendants to the
gods of destruction or is there more to
their true role and purpose in a video
called what if the Angels have a hidden
purpose I argue that there are multiple
clues throughout the series that on top
of being attendants the Angels also have
the duty to monitor their respective
universe in order to determine its
mortal level my argument was that the
angels are like judges who judge the
worth of their universe and then pass
that judgment on to Zeno it has been
shown throughout super that Zeno does
not pay close enough attention to each
individual universe to actually
determine their mortal level I mean in
the future timeline Zeno allowed it to
get to the point that the masu killed
all the deities and nearly took over the
entire multiverse Zeno only acted when
go who summoned him and showed him what
was actually happening so it is pretty
clear that Zeno is not monitoring the
universes himself and the
he is not determining what each
universes mortal level should be this
would explain why the angels tend to
appear neutral and above the fray and
why they tend to act like they don't
feel a personal connection to their
respective universe if my theory is
correct then their job is to be
impartial and to judge and evaluate each
universe just like a teacher's job is to
give an impartial grade to their
students rather than base their grades
on how much they like each student
personally and if we use this same
metaphor then Zeno is like the principal
who decides which students can stay and
which will be expelled based on their
low grades meaning which universe can
stay and which will be erased based on
their low mortal level but that is my
theory let me know if you have other
ones at number 5 what is the grand
priest really up to there have been so
many theories about the grand priest
since he was first introduced many
theories emerged about the grand priest
possibly being evil and the true villain
of the series who is manipulating Zeno
for his own ends others argued that the
grand priest is just a loyal servant of
the Omni King and is merely carrying out
the Omni Kings will on the other hand I
believe in a third option and I've made
numerous videos on this channel arguing
that the grand priest is indeed
manipulating Zeno but he's doing it for
a good cause my theory is that the grand
priest is using the Tournament of power
to teach Zeno a lesson since we know
that Zeno is often bored and he is known
to do unpredictable things when he is in
a bad mood
like for example erase six universes
when he gets angry and since we know
that he doesn't really think about the
consequences of his actions
I believe that the grand priest wants to
use the tournament of power to shows a
know that mortals can be entertaining
and that they have value since Zeno is
having a lot of fun watching the
tournament once the tournament is over
he could come to the conclusion that
erasing universes is wrong because the
mortals who live inside these universes
can be a lot of fun and he might even
decide to bring back all the erased
universes so he can organize more fun
tournament
in the future now I'm not saying that we
would get to see these tournaments
especially now that the future of Dragon
Ball super is uncertain but we could
still get an ending where the universes
are brought back and more tournaments
are announced for sometime down the line
be sure to comment below what you think
about the grand priests true intentions
at number four how did Jaden gets so
strong and in general what is his
backstory when we first meet cheetah and
in Dragon Ball super he has already
believed to be the strongest mortal in
the multiverse and he is already
stronger than his universes god of
destruction as the tournament goes on we
continue to witness the incredible
extent of Durin's power and even Vegeta
and Goku had their most powerful are no
match for Jaden at least for now
but how did Jaden gets so strong we know
very little about his backstory so the
source of Giants power is still a big
mystery to all of us is he simply a
member of an incredibly powerful race
and that explains his power does he have
some sort of special ability that
enhances his power beyond the levels of
ordinary mortals I've read some theories
in the comments sections of previous
videos which stayed that maybe jiren is
originally from one of the six universes
that were erased and the secret of his
power could be somehow connected to the
real reason that the six universes were
erased I think this is an interesting
theory and I have my own theory about
the true source of Giants power but as
of right now we just don't know at
number three what is G Ren's wish even
though we don't know very much about
jiren one thing we do know is that he
has a wish that he desperately wants
granted by super Shenron as you might
recall when he was first asked to fight
for universal evan in the tournament of
power jian refused saying that he is
happy with just staying in universe 11
and protecting it no matter what happens
in the tournament but then when jiren
learns that the winner of the tournament
can have any wish granted to them using
the super Dragon Balls he suddenly
changes his mind and decides to
participate in the tournament at one
point Belmont says that Jian has a wish
that he wants grant
so badly that he is willing to sacrifice
his own principles and when Goku tells
jiren that he wishes to get stronger
jiren tells goku that what he wishes for
lies beyond strength so what is this
wish that jiren wants granted so badly a
wish that lies beyond strength did he
perhaps lose a loved one and wants to
bring them back to life
maybe he is the last of his race of
powerful people who were somehow wiped
out and now he wants to revive them does
he maybe want to turn back time and undo
something he did in the past something
that he regrets and that motivated him
to become a pride trooper in the first
place in order to make up for it or is
the theory that jiren is from one of the
six erased universe is true and gerrans
wish is to revive his home universe I
don't know about you guys but this is
one mystery that I am extremely curious
about and every new episode I am
watching closely to see if we get any
more clues about geon's wish at number
two will we ever see boob in Dragon Ball
super and beyond that will the ending of
Dragon Ball Z remain canon after Dragon
Ball super if you think back to the
ending of Dragon Ball Z known as the
peaceful world saga and to the last
three episodes in particular you will
remember that after a time skip that
takes us beyond the events of Dragon
Ball super chronologically we meet
Ubbe a ten-year-old boy who is the
reincarnation of majin buu aka Kid Buu
but in the body of a good person in
these three episodes we see everyone is
older including pon who is now four
trunks and goten who are now teenagers
and so on so while there is no doubt
that the events of the peaceful world
saga take place after the current events
of Dragon Ball super the question is
will the ending of Dragon Ball Z remain
canon for Dragon Ball super and will we
ever get to see boob in the super anime
some people believe that Dragon Ball
super will not restrict itself by
sticking to the parameters set out by
the peaceful world saga but to be fair
we have been given some important clues
that suggest that the peaceful world
saga still applies
characters like bula the daughter of a
Gina and Bulma who appears in the
peaceful world saga is shown as a baby
in super pond is established as an
incredibly strong baby in super so that
it makes sense for her to be as strong
as she is during the peaceful world saga
and of course although he is not
mentioned by name in super-boob is
referenced briefly in the universe six
saga when Goku mentions that he asked
King Yemma to reincarnate majin buu as a
normal human child during the universe
survival saga denday confirms that the
reincarnation of majin buu is now a
normal boy who lives in a village and
that he is already an extremely skilled
martial artist
Goku believes that the boy is still too
young to participate in the tournament
of power but he agrees to take him on
and train him in the future which of
course he ultimately goes on to do in
the peaceful world saga on top of that
boob does briefly appear in the Dragon
Ball super manga at the end of Dragon
Ball Z Goku leaves together with whom in
order to train him so that he can help
preserve peace in the universe so it
does appear as if super is heading
towards the canonical ending of Dragon
Ball Z at least as far as boob is
concerned do you think that we're going
to see you at some point in the Dragon
Ball super anime and do you think that
super will stick to the original Dragon
Ball Z ending let me know and finally at
number one the big questions that we are
all wondering about how will the
tournament of power end and what exactly
will happen after the tournament I
already made a video talking about some
possible theories for what might happen
after the tournament of power but that
was before we found out that Dragon Ball
super will stop broadcasting on Japanese
TV after March 2018 and while we still
don't know that this is the end for the
series and it still might come back at a
later date the way that the tournament
ends and what happens immediately after
the tournament will give us a good idea
of what the creators of Super have in
mind for the future are the erased
universes going to be brought back or
will they stay erased it is G R and
going to get his wish fulfilled or will
Goku and the universe seven fighters
defeat
and take the super Dragon Balls for
themselves are we going to get a clear
resolution or is this art going to end
on a cliffhanger is a new arc going to
be set up for the future or will
everything go back to being peaceful and
uneventful what happens after the
tournament will give us a good idea
about what's next for Dragon Ball super
is a continuation in the works our new
arcs being planned out or are things
being brought to a clear conclusion that
suggests that we might not get any more
episodes in quite a while this is the
biggest question on all of our minds
right now
and personally I am very anxious to find
out what happens after the tournament
comment your thoughts on what's next for
Dragon Ball super down below I look
forward to hearing everyone's input
about all of these different unsolved
mysteries also let me know if there are
any other big mysteries that you are
wondering about but that I missed in
this video if you enjoyed the Dragon
Ball super content on this channel and
you want to see more be sure to leave a
like to let me know if you are new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and we
are now posting daily anime content on
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar as
always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us pace
Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]